what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so what I want to do is I want to
take a break from all-new all-different
marvel here for a little bit probably
throughout the next week or so and just
because of the fact that there's some
older stories that I really want to
cover it I feel like having one day a
week with spider-man is cool but
spider-man dominates that entire thing
so as you guys will have noticed we did
superior spider-man Goblin nation and
we're going to take a break from that
for a second we'll come back to it but
we're going to take a break for a second
and I want to kind of focus on an Iron
Man extremis or Xtreme that's depending
on how you choose to a choose to
pronounce it because as far as I'm
concerned you know Warren else's story
here is probably the greatest Iron Man
story ever written it's pretty stellar
in terms of how it unfolds but the funny
thing about this is that this is what
Marvel does instead of reboots Marvel
doesn't really like reboot in the
traditional sense instead they give us
stories like Iron Man extremists and
what I mean here is this story basically
coincides with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe planning the phase are really
planning the release of the Iron Man
film and it's kind of funny because in
this story it really just kind of
retcons a lot of Iron Man history really
kind of teacher that you know treats it
like it's brand-new and it was designed
to be that way there was an interview
that Warren Ellis did with Kelly book
calm I think it was where he basically
talked about when he went to go write
this story he didn't read anything about
Iron Man before this maybe a handful of
things like his origin story and that
was really about it for the most part
this is an Iron Man story for a new
generation of readers by a guy who just
didn't worry about any of the previous
Iron Man stuff so the cool thing about
this is that extremists goes in to
execute program and then Civil War and
then maybe like one or two stories after
Civil War I think it's I'm and director
of shield and then you get in you get
into like Matt Fraction and Karen
Gillan's runs which are amazing god they
are so good for Ironman but this
basically sets the stage for everything
about 20 start going into the Civil War
and post-civil war landscapes so the
cool thing about this is in a lot of
ways you will see signs of Iron Man 3 in
this story and while Iron Man 3 was not
necessarily the best amount of Iron Man
film by any standard of measurement
extremis is an amazing story so so
initially we just kind of pick up with
this guy named Mallon whose ingesting
this extremis formula and the way it's
done is that it's basically done through
inoculation which is to say a direct
shot into the bloodstream and so of
course once he begins undergoing this
process the physical appear so the
physical changes are by
in the sense there's blood vomiting
there's all kinds of physical
appearances of the skin so on and so
forth and it's really kind of cool
because a person who ingest extremists
goes into what amounts to more or less a
larval phase where they basically form a
cocoon around themselves and then they
reimburse as something new entirely now
it's kind of interesting because Warren
Ellis is borrowing a little bit of the
inhuman process right like the inhuman
concept you know with the Inhumans a
person is exposed to the Terrigen mist
they go into a cocoon and then they
basically Rhea mean that we think of
them as or at least that was the
traditional theme there's also been
instances like if you go and read when
humans vol 2 for example let us simply
go in there'll be a Mersenne gasps and
they'll just metamour so it's been
depicted different ways over the years
but what we end up doing here is we
actually end up transitioning away to a
guy by the name of dr. Killian now this
is kind of funny because an Iron Man 3
dr. Killian had a far more significant
role in the film than he did in this
particular story in this story like he's
basically typing out a confession about
how the extremis virus had been released
it seems like he's the one that did it
and then he shoots himself and that's
the end of him we never see him again
and so it's really kind of crazy to see
such stark differences but the way that
this is done really the way the story is
done I almost kind of wish Iron Man 3
had followed suit with this story
because it was groundbreaking in terms
of the way it was done but the fact
remains here that we basically pick up
with the introduction of my ax hints now
my intention is really going to be one
of the main characters in this story
alongside for me Stark but killing and
basically typing out a confession more
or less leads to the revelation that he
released the extremis virus out into the
general public which resulted in this
particular guy Mallon getting the virus
and then going forward doing whatever it
is that he does now again we still don't
know the full impacts of everything
that's going on all we simply know is
that a person who ingested this virus
gained some measure of abilities but at
this point we switch over to a meeting
that Tony Stark is having with a guy by
the name of John Pillinger now John
Pillinger is really just kind of
reporter but he's involved in yellow
yellow journalism which is to say he's
involved in a goal of basically
uncovering seedy information and then
bringing that seedy information to light
and so because of that he's working with
Tony Stark and the idea here is that
Warren Ellis is really just kind of
focusing on giving the new reader an
understanding of what Tony Stark is
about because remember this is just
designed to be a jumping-off point and
so what we really get here is this
explanation on the history of stark to
industry
that's not wildly complicated it's not
extremely long and drawn-out it's pretty
to the point more or less what we're
told here is at Stark Industries
initially gained a success by being a
weapons manufacturer by gaining
contracts from the US government and
getting involved in the military
industrial complex the result is that
yes Stark Industries has made a lot of
different weapons that have been used in
the idea of conflict and yes John
Pillinger is really kind of looking at
this and saying you are inherently a
weapons manufacturer the Iron Man suit
was made by you know presumably Stark
Industries the Iron Man suit is by
definition a weapon because that's what
you guys make now the counter-argument
that Tony Stark makes here is that no
that's not the case the Stark Industries
has made weapons in the past but the
goal is to essentially turn over a new
leaf the goal is to effectively create a
new legacy for stark international for
Stark Industries and in turn find a way
to make the world a better place and so
what this does is it really kind of
updates the origin of Tony Stark in a
lot of different ways back when Tony
Stark first appeared in Marvel Comics in
the 1960s he was a guy that was rooted
in the Vietnam War and attached a lot of
stories that were coming up in the 60s
tied into the Vietnam War in a lot of
different ways with Tony Stark he was
designed to be in the
military-industrial complex and so it
made sense that he was going to be a guy
who would basically be making weapons
for the US military and the result is
that some of these minds had basically
fallen loose out of a crate one of them
had detonated and it exploded resulting
in Tony Stark receiving shrapnel in his
chest now this is markedly different
from the origin that we're used to in
the films and that's why there's given
pink that's why there's a little bit of
kind of going back and forth the comics
in some ways maintain their own autonomy
in the sense that they are not directly
influenced by the movies now recently
that's changed there was an interview
that the head guy axel Alonso dead with
Newsarama I think where he said that the
goal was to basically bring the comics
more in line with the movies to create
some identifiable pieces for people who
are getting into the comics because of
the movies but again the comics
themselves really still maintain their
own autonomy to a degree and so as this
interview begins to wrap up where John
Pillinger had more or less try to draw
this conclusion that despite twenty
Starks best efforts everything he's done
has made him a weapons manufacturer
that's what he is and that's what he
what he always will be he poses the
question to John you've been doing this
for all this time but you've never
actually changed anything you know
you're you're a person that just says
hey there's a problem over there and
then just doesn't do any
to fix it because it's too inconvenient
or because he just doesn't have the
power to do it if you think you've
actually done something then what is it
what have you changed how have you made
the world a better place and that's
really the question that John can't
answer and so the point that xx start is
sitting home here is that you know
you're one of those folks out there
who's just kind of like hey there's an
issue and then now it's somebody else's
responsibility to take care of you know
raising awareness that kind of a thing I
mean raising awareness only matters if
people don't know about it otherwise
you're just a lazy activist and so
because of that it's really kind of one
of these funny scenarios you know we're
sort of turning the tables on a reporter
but switching back over to now and what
just basically shows us is this cocoon
stage this larval stage nothing too
major here just kind of showing us you
know the process under which people go
whenever it is they're they're exposed
to extremists but ultimately Tony Stark
actually dons a suit and then just kind
of takes off now what it is that Warren
Ellis is doing here is focusing on this
nature of Tony Stark in terms of what it
is that he does now we as readers are
familiar with this that Tony Stark will
just Don his Iron Man suit and then just
sort of take off to clear his own mind
now he usually does this around earth
and more recent stories he actually left
the earth which is when he joined the
guardians of the galaxy for it's fun but
the fact remains here in the middle of
all this his mind actually begins to
transfer back to when he was younger and
he first met Maya Hansen of course the
two of them basically sharing drinks and
then you know engaging in some some
romantic actions and so on and so forth
but when Maya calls him up she has his a
meet intermediate and total attention
you know of course her response is hey
look you know I need to talk to you
about something you know we said that if
we ever call one another we would always
answer you know that sort of thing and
so when Tony Stark responds to her call
what she basically does is bring him on
or at least inform him a little bit
about something called the extremest
technology now she's very very
cloak-and-dagger about it she doesn't
really say a whole lot to him about what
it is that's going on in Scott she
basically just sort of admits hey look
you know my my boss Killian basically
killed himself we're trying to figure
out why trying to figure out what's
going on of course Tony Stark basically
Jack's Killians hard drive Sims lost
something after one of his guys to be
analyzed and while that's going on they
actually transition over to a guy named
Sal this of course is a future version
of Sal curve le over at Comic Con
now what this guy's now says it looks
like Sal man like look at him look at
that guy he looks like Sal in like ten
years that's exactly that's exactly how
he will look the goatee and
here and all that stuff it looks like
it's going to be south um but but that's
remained here that uh this guy is
actually a new introduction into the
Ironman landscape and this again is one
of those examples where Warren Ellis is
just kind of folding over new things you
know into the comics and so on the only
information that we're really given is
that this guy's Chow seems to have been
an instructor or a mentor of some kind
for both Tony Stark and Maya Hansen in a
sense but he basically saw them as
people who would Herald the future they
would lead to the future and create
better things but the irony of all this
is he really pointed the failings of
Tony Stark he says hey look your biggest
problem is that you are one swept up in
yourself and two you never really think
outside the box now of course Sal
doesn't know about the whole idea of
Ironman of Tony Stark being Ironman but
the other half of the city draws is the
concept that Maya Hansen will always
play second fiddle to somebody else
because her ambitions never lead hurted
wanting to be the number one person this
is combined with the fact that there's
an inherent glass ceiling she can only
ever go so far and so even if she is
wanting to be the number one person
she'll just never really get to that
point right so again this is really kind
of hitting home at the idea that Tony
Stark's never really lived up to his
full potential in Maya Hansen always had
her own shortcomings again kind of
focusing on the nature of these
characters the the tidbits and failings
of these characters but while all this
is happening we end up having Malin who
actually enters an FBI office an FBI
field office and as he makes his way in
there we're given an example of what a
person would extremists can do that
they're given super-strength they're
getting super speed that he's able to
completely overpower these guys in the
FBI their guns don't work none of it
matters and he systematically takes out
every last one of them now of course
following this he basically begins
breeding fire a lot of what you guys saw
in Iron Man 3 is basically what you're
seeing here that's one of the elements
of stayed intact the nature of
extremists what people can do who
possess it so on and so forth D of
course disables the elevators allows the
building to engulfed in flames and
everybody inside is effectively killed
and so because of this we end up having
Tony Stark in Maya Hansen takeoff and
this is when Tony says look I need to
know what I'm up against I need to know
about this extremist stuff now this is
really really cool and the reason why I
say that is because of the fact that an
odd running theme in Marvel Comics is
Captain America's Super Soldier Serum
almost every single organization known
group or something like that has in some
former fashion tried to duplicate the
Super Soldier Serum and just hasn't been
successful the entire existence of
weapons Plus was designed for the
purpose of bringing in the Super Soldier
Serum and then trying to duplicate it
after it was used on Steve Rogers the
problem is that the secret of the serum
died with Abraham Erskine and the result
is that no one's been able to replicate
it perfectly ever since this particular
instance this extremist virus is
basically featured farms attempt to
create their own Super Soldier program
the issue is that it was supposed to be
contained it was supposed to be
maintained only certain people were
supposed to be able to use it somehow or
another this guy Mallon managed to get
his hands on it he was inoculated with
it and it basically sent him reeling and
going crazy and so on
the other half of this is that the
extremis virus basically improves on
human physiology which is to say it
rebuilds damaged organs it restores
damaged tissue we're not really given
any indication if it basically regrows
severed limbs but the implication seems
to be that it can it basically takes
over it hijacks the entirety of the
body's genetic code and it treats it
like a computer program and it just
begins rebuilding lost components or
restoring broken aspects and so on and
so forth and so the result of this is
that Tony Stark Himself donned the
Ironman suit and races off to deal with
Mallon now of course Tony Stark gets
wrecked it gets absolutely decimated
between Mounds super-strength his super
speed so on and so forth Stark just
cannot keep up I mean it's just an
absolute crushing blow I mean none of
his attacks are working his repulsors
aren't working his secondary assault
systems aren't working nothing he has is
pulling off anything whatsoever so the
result is that Mallon is able to
basically overcome Tony Stark and then
essentially bail out and complete his
ultimate goal which we'll find out what
that is shortly but with Tony Stark
having them you know battered and beaten
to such an extreme degree he's
effectively bleeding to death inside of
his own Iron Man suit and that's really
been danger of starch suit in a lot of
ways Iron Man is like Luke Cage right I
mean Luke Cage is a guy that has
indestructible skin but if you drop him
out of a plane from 20,000 feet in the
air sure his skin won't break but his
brain will smash against his skull his
organs will probably liquefy on impact I
mean you can destroy his body physically
on the inside it's just getting through
his skin that's the problem Tony Stark
it's the exact same way he's got this
hard exterior shell with the Iron Man
but underneath that is soft tissue it's
skin it's organs it's brain so on and so
forth and so all I would take is a hard
enough of an impact and suddenly his
arms and legs are broken inside of his
own suit now this isn't the first time
we've seen that I mean there was a story
of what does it Punisher the end when
there's some kind of a glitch in the
system
Iron Man suit freezes and he can't get
out and his suit basically turns into a
tomb he's locked inside of his own suit
for something like five days and then
dies its socked it was it was like
caromed sucks he was it was a terrible
way to go it's like the most haunting
thing to Punishers talking about it and
he's like they said he screamed for like
five days that was it he said it was
like five days before the screaming
stopped or something along those lines I
don't remember but when I went away to
go just being locked in an in an iron
tomb like that that blows balls but the
fact remains with my enhanced and
basically being contacted by Tony Stark
and Tony Stark himself going directly to
her facility this plays out in a way
that we basically expected in the sense
that with Tony Clarke's body I was in
experiencing you know internal bleeding
and so on and so forth with the
revelation that Malins goal is to
basically head to Washington DC and
attack the federal government what this
does is it basically allows 20 Stark to
offer a little bit of discussion about
his own suit as well as what his
intentions are and what we end up
finding out here his attorney Sark
himself despite all his attempts when he
started developing the Iron Man suit
because of the fact that this story
basically treats everything before as if
it never really happened or never really
existed all we're really told here is
that Tony Stark had basically made an
Iron Man suit he's improved on it over
the years but at the end of the day it's
still funky it's still large it's not
necessarily as streamlined as you would
like it to be and the suit reacts to his
physical movements instead of what it is
that he genuinely wants to do and so his
idea is to undergo the extremis process
and basically make the suit part and
parcel to himself and that's exactly
what happens once he undergoes the
process with the extremity once he's
basically you know granted the extremest
technology what he does is he begins
displaying his abilities to tamiya
Hanson now of course he's basically
giving himself these little ports you
know all along his skin these little
openings and his suit basically emerges
from the opening itself and so we're
previously he would basically use his
Iron Man suit you know when he would be
able to punch and kick and so on and so
forth now the suit responds to his
thoughts so the suit does what his mind
wants him to do instead of what is
and legs wanted today now this is really
kind of a small thing but when you're
finding a guy that can move 300 miles an
hour that makes all the difference
because moving at the speed of thought
is almost infinitely faster than moving
at any kind of measure of super speed
the only exception to that is like the
flash but the fact remains that with
regards to Tony Stark
he wants his suit to function according
to his own wishes and wants now this
also makes life a lot easier for him and
the reason why is because whenever it is
that he wants to become Iron Man he has
to fly his suit directly to him you know
he has to like put it in a crate and
then go to the crate and then open the
crate and then put the pieces on one
piece at a time the legs and then the
arms and the chest and in the helmet
he's got to go through all these steps
and all that kind of stuff with extra
mint
he can just recall his suit directly to
him he can basically put it on no matter
where he is or what he's doing and it
certainly streamlines the entire process
and so what this does is it basically
wraps around to the end of the extremest
story in the sense there was iron man's
new technology his new abilities moving
a super speed someone and so forth it's
almost like moving his arms or his legs
the suit is there but it's really it's
almost like it's not there it's almost
like his body it's just extremely
durable you know so the suits an
extension of his own mind this is
combined with the fact that he's
basically a living computer now and so
he can tap into almost any computer
network he can access satellites the
whole nine yards he can do virtually
anything he wants to and so going
against mal and we're now in Lieutenant
to attack Washington DC Tony Stark is
able to stop him and able to basically
outmaneuver him in every single way it's
just kind of funny to see it all unfold
because ultimately I mean Mallen really
doesn't have much of a chance here now
of course what this does is basically
end in Mounds defeat but it requires
Tory start to kill him and that's really
what the idea was it was going on here
you know we're mouths we just will not
step back from Alan simply will not walk
away Tony Stark has no choice but to
kill him now this throws into stroke
relief the nature of man he's not a guy
who's just attacking arbitrarily with no
real you know lost desires he has
motivation he's a guy who's rooted in
the idea that his parents were killed by
the ATF the Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco
and Firearms now of course they were
killed because of the fact that they
were basically you know engaging in
weapons dealing in arms dealing someone
and so forth but it was bringing in this
this concept of you know the state
versus individual rights and it was
really kind of kind of cool to see a
play out I mean really kind of
here was very indicative of like you
know Timothy McVeigh and like Waco Texas
and stuff like that a little bit of a
history lesson for those you guys you
know now Waco Texas happened because a
UPS driver accidentally dropped a
package before he got into the building
and discovered there were firearms
inside and so he reported it to the
local police they reported to the FBI
the FBI reported to the ATF since the
ATF are the ones that deal with firearms
this resulted in the ATF basically
launching an investigation into the
Branch Davidians which was run by David
Koresh ultimately it turned out that
David Koresh was engaging in polygamist
marriage with underage girls the FBI and
the ATF basically had a standoff for
something like 50 or 70 days or
something like that I can't rock top my
head eventually the FBI raided the place
and like 70 something Branch Davidian
men women and children were killed as a
result of like fires that were set or
firefights whatever the case may be now
Timothy McVeigh was watching all the
events unfold that felt like the
government was overstepping its bounds
and so as a result he wanted to start a
revolution within the United States and
did so by blowing up half of the
Oklahoma City bill that's why that
happened this is kind of a reflection of
that in the sense that it's a guy who's
come to believe that the u.s. government
is vastly overstepping its bounds now
this is also one of those things worse
just conveniently ignoring everything
else like his parents were dealing drugs
and his parents were involved in illegal
assault rifle rifle distributing you
know they were engaged in a litany of
illicit acts none of which should have
involved a child in any form or fashion
and so again it's really one of those
things where it's just kind of selecting
what memories are chosen and what
memories are just kinda like well you
know the factor too inconvenient and
that sort of thing but ultimately you
know his standing gets the better of it
and as a result Tony Stark's forced with
no other option than to basically use
the uni-beam from his chest to blow a
hole through Mallon and then destroy his
head using his own repulsors and so
that's really yet I mean that's that's
really all it comes down to now while
all that was happening with Tony Stark
being able to move as fast as he is with
his mind being a living computer tapping
into satellites and all different kinds
of things there was one piece of
information that Maya Hinson dropped
that basically revealed that she was
involved in this entire scheme when Tony
Stark and Maya went to go access the
extremis vault
she said the vault needs two keys one
belong to Killian the other belonged to
me and this is when Tony Stark realizes
that the entirety of the extremis virus
was released not just by Killian but by
Hansen her
and the explanation that she offers is
their job was to basically develop the
extremis virus or develop something that
could be used you know for medical
technology different things like that
but the issue was that the US government
wanted to use it for nefarious purposes
when they told the US government they're
not going to weaponize extremists the US
government pulled their funding and so
the only way for Maya Hansen and and
Killian to basically keep futurepharm
working was to sell off extremists to
the highest bidder which is what they
did
resulting in Mallen getting the
extremist virus and then everything
taking place in this story so again it's
really kind of a cool idea it's a really
really cool set of events and it's
definitely one of my favorite stories
from from the entirety of the ironman
run but the other half of this story
significance and why it's so important
is because of the fact that this sets
the stage for virtually everything that
comes after and so if for example you
sat down and you wanted to read ironman
before the events of secret wars you
start with extremists and work your way
forward and that's all you need to do
you can read civil war if you want to
you don't really have to but you can
just kind of go with this and then just
work your way forward with your iron man
titles and that's really it you don't
need to read anything before this came
out I mean you can you could read like
demon in a bottle or you can read armor
Wars or something like that but those
are by no means necessary for
understanding anything that comes after
iron man extremis but with that being
said guys if you are new here to come
this explain make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the Rob
fork if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]